أصبح الرجل المعروف باسم الأب الروحي
للذكاء الاصطناعي الآن خائفًا من
التكنولوجيا ذاتها التي ساعدها
الرائد جيفري هينتون في ترك Google
لتحذير العالم من مخاطر
أبحاث الذكاء الاصطناعي التي دامت عقودًا ، والتي
شكلت منتجات وأنظمة الذكاء الاصطناعي التي
نستخدمها اليوم  وفي عام 2018 ، كان
فائزًا مشاركًا في جائزة
نوبل لعلوم الكمبيوتر ، وهو الآن يقول
إنه يأسف لعمله وهنا
يتحدث إلى بي بي سي ،
المشكلة الآن أننا اكتشفنا
أنها تعمل بشكل أفضل مما توقعنا
قبل بضع سنوات ،
ما الذي نفعله للتخفيف من المخاطر طويلة المدى
للأشياء الأكثر ذكاءً مما
نتحكم فيه ،
وينضم هينتون إلى مجموعة متنامية من
الخبراء الذين يخشون أن يؤدي الذكاء الاصطناعي السيئ
إلى انقراض
الجنس البشري اليوم Samsung  منعت
موظفيها من استخدام أدوات مثل chat gbt
بسبب مخاوف أمنية في الوقت نفسه ،
أعلنت شركة IBM العملاقة في مجال تكنولوجيا المعلومات أنها ستتوقف
مؤقتًا عن التوظيف لأدوار يمكن أن يشغلها الذكاء الاصطناعي
مما يعرض ما يقرب من 8000
وظيفة للخطر في السنوات الخمس المقبلة ،
فكيف نبتكر و  حماية
مستقبلنا من خلال ضمان التوافق الأخلاقي المزعوم
لهذه التكنولوجيا المتوسعة ،
سنناقش السياسة العامة في لحظة
ولكن أولاً مع أحد الخبراء الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة الذكاء الاصطناعي ،
تخمين كونوليهي الذي انضم إلي
الآن هنا في لندن ، شكرًا
جزيلاً لك حقًا.  أنت تشارك مخاوف جيفري
هينتون ،
هل تعتقد تمامًا كما يعتقد لأنني
أقتبس منه أنه ليس من غير المعقول أنه
يمكن أن يؤدي في الواقع إلى
انقراض الجنس البشري ليس فقط لأنه
ليس مستحيلًا ، أعتقد أنه من
المحتمل جدًا للأسف وأنا '  ليس فقط
الشخص الوحيد الذي يقول هذا المزيد والمزيد من
الأشخاص مثل هينتون الذي هو بالفعل
الأب الروحي لهذا المجال كما
قلت بالفعل إن أقرب ما لدينا إلى
أينشتاين في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي هو الآن
يأخذ هذه المخاطر على محمل الجد
ويذهب  للجمهور
للتحدث عنهم حقًا ، حسنًا ، هذا أمر
بائس جدًا ، أعني أنك تقول إنك تعرف أنه ليس
فقط من الممكن تصور أنه يمكن أن يفعل كيف يمكن ، وفقًا للناس
العاديين ، ما هو
الخطر الحالي وطبيعة هذه التكنولوجيا
التي تشكل خطورة كبيرة بالنسبة لنا الشركات التي  من
خلال العمل على هذه التقنية ، فأنت
تعلم أن Google تفتح الذكاء الاصطناعي في أنظمة أخرى
بشكل صريح في أهدافها لأن ما
يقولون إنهم يحاولون القيام به هو بناء
ذكاء يشبه الإله أنهم لا يحاولون
بناء مجرد نظام إكمال تلقائي
وهذا هو هدفهم صريحًا.
في تأسيسهم ويعني ما
يعنيه الله مثل هذا شيئًا
يفوق البشر في كل شكل من أشكال
القدرة ، فهو أفضل من البشر في
كل نوع من مهام التفكير ، كل نوع
من المهام الجسدية في مرحلة ما ، كل
نوع من المهام القائمة على المهارات يكون أكثر إبداعًا
في كل طريقة.  أعتقد أنه إذا أنشأنا
نظامًا من أي نوع يكون
أكثر ذكاءً بكثير من الجنس البشري ،
فلا أتوقع أن ينتهي بشكل جيد ،
لذا
ما يمكن فعله الآن ، لذا أعتقد أن بعض هؤلاء
الأشخاص ربما كان جيفري هينتون
أحدهم  أسماء عمالقة الذكاء الاصطناعي والتكنولوجيا الكبيرة
التي نتعرف عليها موقعة ، أعتقد
قبل شهرين أن هناك خطابًا
أكثر من ألف أو ما يقرب من 2000 منهم
للمطالبة بوقف مؤقت ،
هل تتذكر ذلك نعم وماذا
كانوا يقولون وماذا حدث حتى
كان الهدف من هذه الرسالة هو الدعوة
إلى وقف مؤقت لمدة ستة أشهر على الأقل ، لقد
دفعت شخصيًا لفترة أطول
لتطوير
أنظمة ذكاء اصطناعي أكبر وأكثر قوة تم بناؤها
حتى الآن ، لذا أعتقد أنه من المهم جدًا
توضيح هذا الاختلاف بسرعة
بين نظام AI هو نظام برمجي ،
نظام برمجي تقليدي هو أن تكتب
رمزًا بحيث تكتب رمزًا يكتب
المبرمج رمزًا
يحل مشكلة إذا كانت لديك
مشكلة ما وتريد أن تفعل شيئًا
وتكتب الكود لجعله يفعل ذلك الذكاء الاصطناعي
مختلف تمامًا  لا تتم كتابة AIS حقًا ، بل إنها
تشبه إلى حد كبير ما لديك من بيانات عما تريد
تحقيقه ، ولا تعرف كيفية حل
المشكلة ، لديك فقط وصف
أو مثل عينات من المشكلة
ثم تستخدم كميات ضخمة  أجهزة الكمبيوتر العملاقة
لسحق هذه الأرقام إلى حد ما تشبه إلى حد ما بشكل
عضوي تقريبًا برنامجًا
يحل هذه المشكلات ، والأهم من ذلك أنه
ليس لدينا أي فكرة عن كيفية عمل هذه البرامج
داخليًا ، فهي عبارة عن صناديق سوداء كاملة
لا نفهم على الإطلاق كيفية
عمل الأجزاء الداخلية الخاصة بهم ، وهذا أمر علمي لم يتم حله.
مشكلة ولا نعرف
كيف نتحكم في هذه الأشياء ، حسنًا ، هذا
هو الشيء الذي لا أفهمه
لأن
البشر يصنعون الأشياء في
الأجهزة ،
فكيف لا تعرف أن هذا هو الجزء
الذي أجده صعبًا للغاية  لفهم
كيف لا تعرف ، وبالتالي كيف
لا يمكنك أن تعرف كيف
تتحكم فيه ، فهذا سؤال رائع ،
ولذا يمكننا أن نأخذ
أمثلة على التطور التركيبي في
علم الأحياء ، لذلك في علم الأحياء أحيانًا قد
ترغب في بكتيريا تنتج
حليب أفضل ، على سبيل المثال ، صحيح أننا لا
نعرف حقًا كيف تعمل جميع الجينات في
البكتيريا ولكن يمكننا اختيار
بكتيريا الحليب الجيدة التي تعلمون أنه يمكننا الحصول عليها
يمكننا تجربة أنواع مختلفة من البكتيريا
والحفاظ على الأشخاص الذين يصنعون
حليبًا جيدًا حقًا ثم  نقوم بتربية هؤلاء ثم
نحصل على المزيد وما إلى ذلك وهكذا فهو
مشابه تمامًا لذلك ، فهو ليس
مثل هذا تمامًا ولكن بدلاً
من كتابة برنامج ، نحاول فقط
عددًا لا يُصدق من البرامج
ونبحث عن أولئك الذين هم  هذه هي
أفضل البرامج وأفضلها ، لكن
الطريقة التي تتم بها كتابة هذه البرامج ليست
بلغة بشرية وليست في كود بل هي
فيما يسمى بالأوزان العصبية وهو ما
يمكنك أن تتخيله مثل مجرد
قائمة ضخمة من الأرقام مثل مليارات
الأرقام  ومثل المليارات من المقابض على
الصندوق ولديك جهاز كمبيوتر خارق كبير
يلف كل المقابض التي
تعرفها مليارات ومليارات ومليارات
من الوقت حقًا سريعًا حقًا ، وفي
النهاية يجد بعض الإعدادات لـ The
Knobs التي تعمل ولكن ما هذه
المقابض أنت  يعني أنه من غير الواضح ، هل
يمكنك إعطاء فكرة لأولئك الذين ليسوا منتقدين لهذا الأمر
عن كيفية استخدامه
لتحسين البشرية ، هل يمكن لمنظمة العفو الدولية
حل السلام العالمي ، هل يمكن أن تحل
الحرب في روسيا ، هل يمكن أن تحلها كما
تعلم بين إسرائيل  والفلسطينيون
جيدون في هذه المرحلة بالتأكيد ليس
أممم لكنني أعتقد أنه كان من المهم جدًا
أن نكون واضحين مثل ما يجعل الإنسانية
عظيمة إلى حد كبير هو
ذكائنا ، أنت تعرف سبب
عدم كوننا قردة شمبانزي هو أننا نمتلك ذكاءً
نطور كل هذا  التكنولوجيا الرائعة من
حولنا لدينا لغة لدينا
ثقافة تعلمون أننا نطور المجتمعات
والفنون وكل هذه الأشياء الجميلة
هذه كلها أشياء رائعة أحب الذكاء كما
تعلمون أنني أحب أن أكون إنسانًا
أحب كل أصدقائي البشر ولكن
يمكن أن يساعدنا الذكاء الاصطناعي في ذلك  بالطبع نرى
الآن أنك تعرف
ثورة تعرف الأدوات التي تتيح لنا
أتمتة المهام البسيطة أو
المهام المعقدة لإنشاء أشكال جديدة من الفن
أو الوسائط التي تتيح لنا معرفة
ترجمة النص بشكل أفضل بكثير من أي
طريقة سابقة مسموح بها  نحن لأنك
ترغب حقًا في البدء في كسر
الحواجز بين اللغات
لدرجة مفاجئة جدًا في كثير من الأحيان حتى تعرف أنه يمكن
للذكاء في مرحلة ما أن يحل هذه
المشاكل التي تصفها والجوع العالمي
أعني ، نعم ، أعني على الأرجح أنني لا
أعرف بالتأكيد  ليست
الأنظمة الحالية ولكنك تعرف ما إذا كان لدينا نظام
متفوق على البشر في كل
جانب يمكن تصوره ، فأنا أتوقع أن يكون
قادرًا على حل المشكلات التي لا نستطيع نحن البشر
حاليًا حلها ، ما هو
الإيجابي الرئيسي ، أعني أننا نسمع
كلمة الكفاءة  وهو ما يعني
استبدال البشر كما رأينا للتو شركة IBM بكل
ما هو ذكاء اصطناعي نعم وأنت
تعلم أنني أتمنى لو كان لدي قصة إيجابية غير مبررة
ولكن لا توجد
قصة إيجابية للحليف ، وهذا يعني دائمًا أن هذه
مخاطرة كلاسيكية تحدث دائمًا عندما  يتم
تطوير تكنولوجيا حديثة جديدة وأدوات أفضل يتم استبدال بعض الأشخاص ،
وعادة ما يتم إنشاء وظائف جديدة حتى
لا تعرفهم في مرحلة ما ،
سننفد فعليًا من الأشياء التي يمكن
للبشر القيام بها وأعتقد أننا
نقترب من أنك تعرف عندما  إنشاء
المحرك البخاري ، فقد سمح للبشر بالقيام
بالكثير من النكهة المعرفية ، فكروا أكثر في أنه
يمكننا القيام بالمزيد من الكتابة والتحدث
لأن الآلات الآن يمكنها القيام بكل
الأحمال الثقيلة ،
ولكن إذا كانت الآلات تقوم أيضًا بكل
الكلام وكل التفكير بشأن ما
تبقى  لا أعرف في الوقت الحالي أنها لا
تزال مفيدة للغاية حيث أن هناك العديد من
التطبيقات في العلوم والطب
التي تستفيد بشكل كبير من
تكنولوجيا الذكاء الاصطناعي لتتعرف بشكل
أفضل على
البروتينات التي تفهم علاجاتها التي تعرفها أيضًا
وتنتج الفن أو تكتب رمزًا
أجنبيًا